everyone welcome to your daily equation
hope you've had a good day that you're
feeling okay I've had a pretty good day
today I've been working actually on an
article for the New York Times on of all
subjects the question why Art Matters
and you know obviously from the
perspective of a physicist mathematician
you know not someone who is an artist
but it's kind of fortuitous because the
equation that I want to talk about today
is often described and I certainly would
describe it this way as one of the most
beautiful or perhaps the most beautiful
of all mathematical equations and so
this idea of art and aesthetics and
beauty and elegance it kind of all comes
together in this mathematical formula
which makes it you know quite an
appealing subject to to write about to
think about and also a wonderful little
encapsulation of of really what we
physicists what mathematicians mean when
they talk about beauty in mathematics as
you'll see in the equation when we get
to it it just puts together in such a
compact elegant economical equation
different aspects of the mathematical
world and and tying to sperrit things
together into a novel pattern a
beautiful pattern a pattern that that
just fills you with wonder when you look
at it is is what we mean when we talk
about the beauty of of mathematics so
let's jump into the equation and for
this one all I'll need to do a lot of
writing so let me immediately just bring
my iPad up to here and let me bring this
up on to the screen okay good all right
so the formula that I'm gonna be talking
about it is known as Euler's formula or
often Euler's identity and in that we
have this guy Euler in the title here
let me actually just say a couple words
about him I could show you an image but
it's kind of even more fun let me just
swap right back over here yeah so so
these images clearly they're they're
stamps right so this is a stamp from the
Soviet Union from I guess it's the
mid-1950s I think was the two hundred
and fiftieth birthday of Euler and then
we see this picture as well this other
stamp from I think it's from Germany on
the 200th anniversary of may have been
the death of Euler so clearly he's a big
deal if he's on stamps in in Russia and
in Germany so who is he so so Leonard
Euler was a swiss mathematician who
lived in the 1700s and he was one of
those grand thinkers that even
mathematicians and other scientists
would would look to as the epitome of of
mathematical achievement sort of the
epitome of creative thought in the
mathematical sciences he I don't know
the exact number but he was so prolific
Euler left behind something like I don't
know ninety or a hundred volumes of
mathematical insight and I think you
know there's a quote I'll probably get
this wrong but I think it was Laplace
again one of the great thinkers who
would tell people that you had to read
Euler if you really want to know what
mathematics was about because Euler was
the master mathematician and that's
coming from the perspective of somebody
else who was a master mathematician a
master
physicist so so let's get to this this
formula here and let me bring my iPad
back up it's not coming up okay now it's
back up alright good okay so so to get
there and look in deriving this this
beautiful little formula there are many
ways to go about it and the route that
you follow depends upon the background
that you have sort of where you are in
your educational process and look
there's so many different people who
watch this that I I don't know the best
way in for any of you so I'm going to
take one approach is going to assume a
little knowledge of calculus but I'll
kind of try to try to motivate at least
the parts that I can motivate and the
other ingredients if you aren't familiar
with them you know I could just let it
wash over you and and just enjoy the
beauty of the symbols or perhaps use the
discussion that we're having is
motivation to fill in some of the
details and look if I was to do you know
an infinite number of these your daily
equations we cover everything I can't so
I have to sort of start summers where am
I going to begin is a famous little
theorem that you learn when you take
calculus which is known as Taylor's
theorem and how does this go it goes as
follows it says look if you have some
function let me give it a name have some
function called f of X right and Thames
theorem is a way of expressing f of X in
terms of the value of the function at
say a nearby point that I'm going to
call X sub 0 nearby to X you express it
in terms of the value of the function at
that nearby location now it won't be an
exact equality because X can differ from
X naught so how do you capture the
difference in the value of the function
at those two distinct locations well
Taylor tells us that you can get at the
end
sir if you know some calculus by looking
at the derivative of the function
evaluated at X naught times the
difference between X and X naught that
won't be the exact answer in general
rather Taylor says you have to go to the
second derivative evaluated at X naught
times X minus X naught squared and this
one you have to divide through by 2
factorial and just to make it all look
kind of uniform I can divide this one by
1 factorial if I'd like and you just
keep on going you go to the third
derivative and X naught times X minus X
naught cubed over 3 factorial and on it
goes and if you're being careful about
this you have to worry about the
convergence of this series that I've
written which in principle would go on
to infinity I'm not going to worry about
those sort of important details I'm just
going to assume that everything will
work and the subtleties will not come
and sort of bite us in a way that will
invalidate any of the analysis that
we're carrying out ok so what I'd like
to do now is take this general formula
which in principle applies for any
function that's appropriately behaved
that it can be differentiated
arbitrarily many times and we're going
to apply it to two familiar functions
which is cosine of X and sine of X and
again I know that if you don't know what
sine and cosine are then you're probably
not going to be able to follow
everything that I'm talking about but
just to kind of have everything written
down in a complete looking manner let me
just remind you that if I have a nice
triangle like this it really needs to
meet up there at the top and let's say
this angle is X and let's say this
hypotenuse here is equal to 1 then
cosine X will be the length of that
horizontal side and sine X will be the
length of that vertical side so that's
what we mean by cosine and sine and if
you
take a course in calculus and learn some
of the details you will learn you will
know that the derivative of cosine X
with respect to X is equal to a minus
sine of X and the derivative of sine of
X with respect to X is equal to cosine
of X and that's nice because with that
knowledge we can now go back up here to
Taylor's theorem and we can apply it to
cosine and sine so why don't we do that
so let me change colors here so we can
make this pop out a little bit more so
let's look at cosine of X and let's
choose X not the nearby location to be
the value 0 so that will just be most
useful that special case will be most
useful to us so just plugging away into
Taylor's theorem we should look at
cosine of 0 which is equal to 1 when
this angle X is equal to 0 you see that
the horizontal part of the triangle will
exactly equal the hypotenuse so it will
be equal to 1 and now let's keep on
going but to avoid writing down things
that will vanish notice that since the
derivative of cosine of sine and sine of
0 up here is equal to 0 that first order
term will vanish so I'm not even going
to bother writing it instead I'm going
to go right over to the the second order
term and if the first derivative of
cosine a sine then the derivative of
sine will give us the second order term
which will find include the sign will be
minus cosine and cosine of 0 is equal to
1 so the coefficient that we have over
here will just be minus 1 over 2
factorial and upstairs
in fact I mean even just put it
immediately upstairs upstairs I will
have x squared and again if I go then to
the third order term I will have a sine
coming in from the derivative of the
cosine from the second order term
evaluated at 0 will give us 0 so that
term will go away I'll have to go to the
fourth order term and if I do that again
the code
we'll be equal to one I'll get X to the
fourth over 4 factorial and on it will
go so I only get these even powers in
the expansion and the coefficients just
come from the even factorials ok so
that's cool that's for cosine let me do
the same thing for sine X and again it's
matter of just plugging in same kind of
thing in this particular case when I'm
expanding about X not equal to 0 the
first order term will give us sine of 0
which is 0 so it drops out so I have to
go to this guy over here the the zeroth
order term I should say drops out so go
to the first order term the derivative
in this case will give me cosine
evaluating that at 0 gives me a
coefficient of 1 so I will just get X
for my first term similarly I will skip
the next term because its derivative
will give me the term that vanishes at 0
so I have to go on to the third order
term and if I do that and I keep track
of the signs I will get minus X cubed
over 3 factorial then the next term will
drop out by the same reasoning and I get
X to the fifth over 5 factorial so you
see that the sine and that's of course a
1 they're implicitly the sine gets the
odd Exponential's and the cosine gets
the even one so it's very nice a very
simple Taylor series expansion for sine
and cosine fantastic now keep those
results in the back of your mind and now
I want to turn to another function that
that at first sight will seem to have no
connection to anything that I'm talking
about so far so let me introduce a
completely different color I don't know
maybe a maybe a dark green to
distinguish it not just intellectually
but also from the standpoint of the
color palette that I am using and to
introduce this well the function itself
will be the function
e to the X I should say a few words
about what E is since it's pretty
important in that formula there are many
ways to define this number called e
again it depends on where you're coming
from
one nice way is to consider the
following consider the limit as n goes
to infinity of 1 plus 1 over N raised to
the nth power
now now first off just note that like
this definition that we have here has
nothing to do with triangles cosine sign
again that's what I mean by it looks
completely different but let me give you
some motivation for why in the world you
would ever consider this particular
combination this particular limit this
number as n goes to infinity why would
you ever think about that well imagine
that I give you $1 okay I'll give you $1
and I say hey if you give me that dollar
back I'll consider it
alone and I'm gonna pay you interest on
that and let's say I tell you I'm going
to over the course of one year give you
100 percent interest then how much money
will you actually have at the end of
that year how much if I'm the bank right
how much money will you have in the bank
account well you started with $1 okay
and then a hundred percent interest
means that you'll get another dollar in
a minute I'm gonna stop writing down
these dollar signs so you'd have two
dollars well that's pretty good pretty
good interest right 100% but then
imagine you say hey you know maybe you
want to pay me that interest rate but
not all at once maybe you want to pay me
half of that interest in six months and
then six months later give the other
half of the interest rate now that's
interesting because that gives you
compound interest right so in that
particular case
you'd start with $1 okay at the end of
six months I'd give you half a dollar
more and then six months later I'd have
to pay you interest on this which again
if I'm giving you that 50% interest if
you will every six months then this is
the amount of money that I owe you as
you see you're getting interest on the
interest in this particular case that's
why it's compound interest so this gives
me three have some cereal that gives me
nine quarters which is a $2.25 so
clearly it's a little bit better if you
get the interest compounds instead of
two dollars you get two dollars and 25
cents but then you start thinking hey
what if you the bank gives you the
interest every four months three times a
year what would happen in that case well
now I'd have to give you one plus
one-third of the interest in the first
third of the year then I'd have to give
you again one third that 33 and a third
percent interest and the second well I'm
running out of power what if my iPad
dies before I'm done this is so painful
for me to get through this okay I'm
gonna write more quickly so one plus
one-third so in this case you'd get
what's that's four thirds cube so that
would be 64 over 27 which is about two
dollars and 26 cents or so a little bit
more than you had before and again right
you can keep on going so I don't have to
write it all out if you were doing
quarterly compounded interest then you'd
have 1 plus 1/4 to the fourth power aha
look it's 1 plus 1 over N to the end for
n equal to 4 and in this particular case
if you were to work this out let's see
so this would give us 5 to the 4th over
4 to the 4th that'd be 625 over 256 and
that is 2 dollars and I think 44 cents
something like that
anyway you can imagine keep on going and
if you did
this as the exponent goes to infinity
that is your compound in the interest
you infini quickly but you get one over
that amount of the total yearly interest
in each of those installments how much
money would you get and that then is the
limit as n goes to infinity of 1 plus 1
over N to the nth power and you can work
this out and the answer is well
money-wise you get about 2 dollars and
72 cents or if you're not going to limit
it to the just accuracy of pennies the
actual number that you get is a it's a
number that goes on forever 2.71828 you
know it's like pi and that it goes on
forever transcendental number and this
is the definition of e ok so E is on
number and you can then ask yourself
what happens if you take that number and
you raise it to a power called X and
that's your function f of X and and you
and you will learn again in a calculus
class is the beautiful fact and this is
another way of defining this number e
that the derivative of e to the X with
respect to X is just itself e to the X
and this has all sorts of deep
ramifications right if the rate of
change of a function at a given value of
a given argument X is equal to the value
of the function at X then its rate of
growth is proportional to its own value
and that is what we mean by exponential
growth e exponential growth and this is
e to the X exponential growth so all
these ideas come together now given this
fact we can now if I just scroll back
and I hope my iPad is not gonna die it's
it's acting up I can feel it oh come on
would you scroll with me good maybe bad
having too many fingers on it or
something um I can now use Taylor's
theorem but apply it to the function f
of X equals e to the X and since I have
all the derivatives it's straightforward
for me to work it out again I'll expand
it about X naught
equal to zero so I can write then e to
the X if X naught is equal to 0 e to the
0 anything to the 0 is 1 and that will
occur over and over again because all of
the derivatives are just e to the X they
all get evaluated at X not equal to 0 so
all of those derivatives in that
infinite expansion are all equal to 1 so
all I get then is x over 1 factorial
plus x squared over 2 factorial plus X 3
over 3 factorial and on it goes that is
the expansion of e to the X ok now one
more ingredient before we can get to the
beautiful finale the beautiful Euler
identity I now want to just introduce a
little change naught e to the X but e to
the i-x do you remember what is I is
equal to the square root of minus 1
right usually you can't take the square
root of a negative number but you can
define it to be this new quantity called
pi which means that I squared is equal
to minus 1 which means that I cubed is
equal to a minus I which means that I to
the fourth is equal to 1 and that's all
useful because when I plug in to e to
the i-x in these expressions I need to
take various powers not only of X but
also by this little table gives us the
result that I will have so let's just do
that so e to the i-x is equal to 1 plus
I x over 1 factorial now x squared will
involve I squared that's minus 1 so I
get minus x squared over 2 factorial ok
X cubed will involve I cubes I would get
minus I times X cubed over 3 factorial
and I X to the fourth the term I haven't
actually written down there but that
will just give me I to the fourth is
equal to 1 so I'll get X to the fourth
over 4 factorial and on that will
continue to go now let me play a little
game and pull out all the terms that
have no I in it
and those terms that do have an eye on
it so the terms that don't have an eye
gives me one thing I'm a risk changing
colors here please iPad do not die on me
so I will get 1 minus x squared over 2
factorial plus X to the 4th over 4
factorial and keeps on going okay that's
one term + and let me just change colors
again let me pull out an eye and I will
get this first term is X and then the
next term will be minus X cubed over 3
factorial from this guy over here and
then plus X to the fifth over 5
factorial head and written that down but
it's there and on and on it goes
now what's what do you notice about this
if I can scroll up you will notice that
cosine of X and sine of X these
expansions that we had earlier if I now
reflect on what I have here this is just
equal to cosine X plus I times sine X
holy smokes
e to the i-x something that doesn't seem
to have any connection to cosines and
sines
I mean it's compound interest after all
has this beautiful relationship I miss
it I can bring this back with cosine and
sine okay now now for the finale right
let's let X equal to the value PI then
the special case gives us e to the I pi
is equal to cosine of pi plus I sine of
PI now sine of pi is equal to 0 cosine
pi is equal to -1 so we get this
fantastically beautiful formula e to the
I pi equals -1 but I'll write that as e
to the I PI plus 1 equals to 0
and at this point the trumpet's really
should be blaring
everybody should be on their feet
cheering mouth wide open because this is
such a wonderous formula look what it
has in it it has in it the beautiful
number pie that comes in with our
understanding of circles it has this
strange number I square root of -1 it
has this curious number e coming from
this definition that I gave before and
it has the number 1 and it has the
number 0 it has like all of the
ingredients that are kind of the
fundamental numbers of mathematics 0 1 i
pi e they all come together into this
spectacularly beautiful spectacular
elegant formula and and that's what we
mean when we talk about beauty and
elegance in mathematics taking these
disparate ingredients that come from our
attempt to understand circles our
attempt to make sense of the weirdness
of the square root of a negative number
our attempt to make sense of this
limiting process that gives us this
weird number E and of course a number 0
how could there be anything more
fundamental than that and it all comes
together in this beautiful formula this
beautiful Euler identity so you know
stare at that formula paint it on your
wall tattoo it on your arm it is just a
spectacular realization that these
ingredients can come together in such a
profound yet simple looking elegant
mathematical form that is mathematical
beauty okay that's all I wanted to say
today until next time take care this is
your daily equation